first things first
we are for comics by comics and
we've been talking about the earthquake
special and i've gotta tell you dude
the earthquake special has ruined comedy
for me like
i was watching ronnie chang's new
special
yeah and like
it was really it was funny and it was
interesting and it was engaging and
captivating but there was a moment near
the middle
that i i i was watching with my wife and
i audibly said out loud i was like yo
where's the laughs like
because he was setting up a point
that took a little while to get there
but seeing what earthquake did i was
just like yo lpm's lpms lpm's where's
the last per minute
yeah yeah but yeah
that's what i thought about yeah it was
different i would say the uh
the um
aziz on sorry special
yeah
that one was so short
and felt like an earthquake special
because he did it in a tight space
and the laughs carried so that would
felt
like an earthquake like special because
it was very much like hit hit hit hit
and he did it like in a very i mean in a
30 minute kind of like environment but
yeah it's that that earthquake special
is
especially like as the big one for 2022
has kind of ruined
a lot of people's like
expectations of what a special should be
it
it's another level and i think i think
it can ruin also
maybe
like stylistically like
yeah there doesn't have to there doesn't
have to be 12 laps per minute you know
as comedians we can appreciate that
metric and aspire to it but there is
also something to be said about
having a point developing it
yes and i mean
it's got to be funny i know there's also
a trend where it's cool to not get
laughs because you're ironically bombing
but
we do need to make sure there's still
laughs there but also
if you have something to say
to feel comfortable saying it and being
in silence and establishing it for the
payoff at the end
but
i do always have is we're going to talk
about gerard carmichael's new special
uh who his all of his specials are a
prime example of someone
doing what they want to do having a
clear stylistic choice
and committing to it and it's not
earthquake
like laughs per minute but um
it's another way to do comedy and that's
what we always want to encourage comics
is like
the only way is your way you can learn
from us and the classes and workshops
and other comics
but at the end of the day there's no
right way it's your way but at least
make it funny you know be funny but
gerard special is like a unique example
of how to do a comedy special
yeah it's very different it's funny
because i was watching the carmichael
special
and i was doing my homework and i was
counting the laughs per minute and then
i just put my pencil down and i just
said that's not what this is about right
i finished the rest of the special and i
still enjoyed it i enjoyed it
but it wasn't
it wasn't i wouldn't actually call it
a comedy special i'd call it a special
starring the comedian gerard carmichael
and the reason i say that
is
it was more like
a
like a come to jesus moment kind of
thing it was more like
it felt like an intervention but we
weren't trying to intervene in anything
that jerrod was going through we were
just in a room where he's like it's you
know what it was it felt like you did
you ever have family meetings
where everyone's like hey guys gather up
where your dad's like gonna tell you big
news right and he's like
moved to like virginia right i remember
this because we had a family meeting
where
my dad like he goes through he's like
this is why we're moving all this other
stuff
that's what the gerard carmichael
special felt like he's like all right
everybody gather around everyone that i
know gather around let me tell you the
story about
my
like
what i'm going through and that's what
that special felt like and i enjoyed it
for that
and took off the lens of trying to make
it like oh this is
this is just all pure comedy and he had
jokes throughout it but he also
forcefully also did things that you
aren't necessarily supposed to do in
comedy
and i appreciate that he did do that
because he had audience members asking
questions and he talked through them as
part of the special
and the questions weren't comedic
questions
they were like hey how do you feel about
your mom like there were hard-hitting
questions about the situation that he's
going through so it like i think you
just have to respect that the special
itself was more like a family meeting a
family get together let's gather around
gerard's got something to say
and it was i i enjoyed it because i
thought it was super artistic i agree
and i enjoyed it as well and i i think
i'm glad that this came out
um just because we had been leaning on
laughs per minute so much so i'm glad
as we continue to do this show that we
can start to kind of
look at it from multiple angles and
don't because a lot of young comics
listen to this and i don't want people
to start thinking
oh there wasn't a laugh every five
seconds so it's not a good special like
so i think this is a great time for this
special to come up just for that reason
if anything to show what's possible you
know bo burnham directed it who bose
directed other of gerard specials i
think he directed chris rock's newest
special
um so uh it's yes stylistically it's
super unique super
specific to gerard gerard and like ron
said it's like a one-man show
yeah which is a good way to put it yeah
yeah
and i i think what i really took away
from it
and it's something that he emphasized in
the special
i think at one point someone yelled out
and then
maybe like retreat a little bit or he's
like no please like speak up you know i
think what he said like we're a family
like this is how this it's only going to
work if we feel like we're in a family
together or something like that so he
set that expectation too
for sure yeah yeah and
i so respected the audience
for like
taking themselves
and putting themselves into his shoes
and like
leaning into like because
there were times when like the
conversation felt uncomfortable you're
like
wow like
he's going through it and you can see
him going through it
on stage
yeah
he's processing
deep emotions
while doing a comedy special
and to watch that and to also watch the
audience be engaged in that was actually
very
kind of cool it was something i've never
i've never seen
that before
where
an artist
is like
having a moment
and then
an audience is watching the moment there
were a lot of
silences
that were quiet
and just like you could hear a pin drop
and you were just
waiting
for something to break it but it was
also okay that it wasn't broken as well
yeah yeah i think i heard a musician i
can't hear which one it was but they
said like
you can make an audience clap but can
you make an audience quiet as well and
he made the audience quiet and i i'm i'm
guilty of this of like hiding behind
laughs sometimes and like and not going
there but making the easy joke to escape
the discomfort that this topic may be
bringing up
so sure watching this as someone 12
years in the game i was like
i want to be more
thoughtful and intentional one he opens
up let's talk about secrets so
immediately i'm like well what are some
of my secrets and could i talk about
these things you know because i do
i do want to get more personal now i
feel like i'm in like kind of the next
chapter of my career and like
i i do want to get deeper and talk about
more personal things
and yeah seeing this special really kind
of inspired me to be like okay well this
is how it's done at the top this is how
it's done at the highest level are you
willing to do this and um it really
inspired me to like really kind of
start going to those places and ask him
well what are my secrets and maybe
am i comfortable talking about them you
know it's it's scary and he does it i
mean beautifully
yeah yeah yeah he definitely has given a
template
to
talk about uncomfortable conversations
that you are still processing and you
don't have a solution and or a joke for
at the moment
yep like
and i mean i would love to have like
figured out like
how he prepared for this
because it felt
very organic on stage
yeah yeah it did i'm i'm wondering yeah
how much it was thought out versus just
like i'm gonna go up there and talk
about this you know and i guess the big
thing
that happens in the special like the
headline is gerard comes out in his
comedy special you know he like he
basically says i'm gay and then there's
like applause and he was on seth meyers
and talk he's like i came out in my
special and people like applaud and he's
like i love being in new york people
just applaud me for being gay now he's
like
but it's like you could you could see
him like like mindfully like talking
through this like he's trying to figure
it out with the audience which was very
interesting to see adam
on a special
yeah
so i think that's the big takeaway for
comics is like
yeah how can you create a connection
with the audience you know like create
an authentic connection that's memorable
that you actually feel
you know it's another thing i've been
watching american idol
you know with my with my wife you know
we like the american idol and the best
the best singers
your wife doesn't have to be the excuse
for you watching american eye don't you
guys go with it yo i'm with it
i'm with it yo
i love it i really do and my favorite
singers are the ones that you can feel
what they're singing
and like you feel the emotion and i was
like can people do that with my comedy
you know we tell comics to write from
emotional places like but am i doing
that and how can i do it better because
i want i want to evoke that emotion and
that connection with the audience like
gerard does it's
it it's it's a new level and i think
everyone should definitely check it out
and it's also why
i think he's got so many fans um
old
like there are people that just f with
gerard carmichael that are like yo
that dude's got something
and he's just got a fandom that is very
like
unique that people just mess with him
and mind you this is a guy who's already
had a network television show
he's already had several specials he's
kind of doing comedy at his own pace
like he's just doing exactly what he
wants to do in comedy um and he's doing
it like his way so just to put something
out like this i really like it because i
feel like
there isn't a template for something
of this nature
really yeah
so yeah i i definitely i enjoyed it i
agree
yeah
i was like oh i needed that it was it's
like oh just you just don't get a lot of
there's not a lot of gerard carmichael's
in the game
oh my god i mean well yeah there's
clearly only like one girard like even
the comment the special he did at the
comedy store
he's like using a notebook he has a
notebook during a comedy special
and i personally what that was produced
by spike lee yeah spicy
one of the greatest directors of all
time produces special and this dude has
a notebook it was just
yeah like
just the the breakage and just like oh
let me just do it my way
so
yeah it's just it's very like
high quality but also just like very
admirable
yeah yeah so check it out comics and
just see what's possible in this format
um
but you know funny you know please do be
funny i i don't want people to be like
all right never mind i don't want to be
a comedian i want to do ted talks at
open mics you know still be funny
but
you see you see how gerard
when you watch the special you'll see
how he walks the line from both
but everything's very intentional he's
not like i want to say something
risque just for the sake of people like
tweeting about it like what he's doing
is very intentional and it's done at a
very high level
but it's also aspirational
for like the connection he creates with
the audience so
watch it through that lens